a question answer okay a question for my
director you ready let's do it
how do you make a character massive
imposing and dominating oh well first of
all we cast you
it's a great answer Mike thank you thank
you second give the cinematographer the
space to put the camera low pointing up
like Spike Lee and his legendary
cinematographer Ernest Dickerson did
with Malcolm X as you can see here
with their signature double Dolly shot
cinematographers find new ways to push
the limits of film and storytelling each
year back in the day director Orson
Welles and his cinematographer Greg
Tolan had to be Innovative because they
were using a camera like this
oh that's a beast
yeah I mean that was before cell phones
so they actually cut a hole in the floor
and physically lowered the camera
okay
um
that's what I call a workout and a flex
it's pretty big flex but the result was
uh was this shot
sometimes the simplest Solutions are the
most creative
in fact Creative Vision is a trait
shared by the next outstanding artist
here are the nominees for achievement
and cinematography
All Quiet on the Western Front Jaden's
friend
Gordo false Chronicle of a handful of
truths Darius kanji Elvis Mandy Walker
Empire of light Roger deacons tar
glorian Hofmeister
okay and the Oscar goes too
All Quiet on the Western Front
Jane's friend studied Electro technical
engineering and got his first chance to
work on sets as an electrician an
advocate of mentorship in the industry
he has inspired to become a filmmaker at
13 when he first saw alien
[Applause]
well it's not my birthday
um but I feel like it is
I mean what an honor Academy thank you
so much thank you for
everything and my fellow nominees
your work is just outstanding and
inspires me and just thank you for
everything my entire crew
who
made this happen for me and made me look
better than I am
my darling mum and dad who when I was uh
said I want to run off
to the circus join the circus
of the film industry
they believed in me and thank you
and my beautiful wife encouraging it
just my brother and my sister who just
yeah pushed me and push me and push me
and Edward Berger
I'm up
just thank you so much I just I'm sorry
if I've missed anyone out but thank you
from the bottom of my heart thank you so
much thank you so much
[Music]